These people on the far right,
they are not patriots.
They are not serving the interest of the European citizens,
but the interest of dictatorships and autocracies.
And this makes it even more important colleagues,
to build strong pro European,
constructive majority in the next European Parliament.
After the European election,
we will set a path for the next five years.
The beginning of the next legislature will be our moment of truth.
Will we steer the European Union
in the direction of climate neutrality,
of defending democracy and freedom?
Or will we follow the same old recipes
that are risk harming our European economies
and global competitiveness?
I think you know the answer that I would give to that.
So let us fight constructively in this election campaign.
But then let us build a constructive
pro European majority after this election. Thank you very much.